charge increases are now beginning to
drop out of the annual calculation of
the Consumer Price Index moreover
wholesale gas spot prices have fallen by
around 50 percent since November and gas
future prices have also come down
markedly
the charts should come up shows the
mpc's central projection for inflation
which is conditional on a market implied
path for bank rate that Peaks at around
four and a half percent by the middle of
this year
and the central projection Consumer
Price inflation Falls to around four
percent towards the end of the of the
year
the purple bars on the chart illustrate
that a sizable part of this Fork can be
explained by Direct effects from Energy
prices
however the expected fall in inflation
is not just about energy prices
Global price pressures are easing as
supply chain disruptions have lessened
across most of the world
and we therefore expect headline
inflation to fall rapidly based on Lower
external cost pressures more broadly
and this one alleviate some of the very
big shock to National real income that
we have had as a country
but while external pressures are easing
other indicators of inflationary
pressures have proved firmer than
expected
the labor market remains tight by
historical standards and annual private
sector pay growth increased to 7.2
percent in the free months to November
which surprised on the upside
as you can see in this chart while core
Goods inflation has fallen Services
Consumer Price inflation Rose to a
30-year high of 6.8 percent in December
above what we expected in the November
monthly policy reports
Bank staff project that Services
inflation will rise further in the near
term consistent with the strength in
wages and other costs facing service
sector companies
it is price and wage setting Dynamics in
the UK economy that ultimately determine
how long it takes to return inflation to
Target on a sustainable basis
so while we're confident that inflation
will come down this year
developments over the coming quarters
will be crucial in determining how
quickly overall inflationary pressures
abates
judging sustainability requires us to
look further ahead and that's where the
uncertainties increase
in the monetary policy committee's best
Collective judgment the most likely
outcome is that an increasing degree of
economic slack alongside reduced
external pressures leads Consumer Price
inflation to fall below the two percent
Target from around spring 2024 next year
besides the market implied path for bank
rate this is conditional on a wholesale
Energy prices following their respective
Futures curves over the whole forecast
period
so in other words the forecast suggests
that inflation will come down and that
it will fall quite sharply
but events May not unfold in this way
with inflation currently above 10 we are
in an Uncharted Territory
Energy prices may not fall by as much as
currently expected in financial markets
and even if they do this period of very
high inflation could play into price and
wage setting in the UK economy to a
greater extent than we assume in our
Central projection
the tightness of the labor market
reinforces this risk
for this reason we think the risks
around our Central projection for
inflation shown in this chart are skewed
significantly to the upside
and more so than at any time in the
history of the Marshall policy committee
our decision to increase Bank rates
today despite a weak Outlook in our
Central projection reflects these
uncertainties
uncertainties over the extent to which
external and domestic inflationary
pressures develop over the coming
quarters
and wider uncertainty so the trajectory
of the economy
and inflationary Dynamics further ahead
we have done a lot on rates already the
full effect of that is still to come
through
but it is too soon to declare Victory
just yet
inflationary pressures are still there
and we can see that in the data and we
hear it from our agents
and we need to be absolutely sure that
we really are turning the corner on
inflation
and that's why we've increased bank rate
today
and that is why we will of course
continue to monitor the data very
carefully
I want to say a few more things about
the key judgments underlying the
forecast because these are important
the first key judgment is about
potential Supply
the level of output the economy can
sustain without generating too much
inflation
over recent years the UK economy has
been hit by a series of significant
economic shocks that have affected
potential Supply
this includes the change in the trading
relationship with the European Union
the covert pandemic and developments in
global Energy prices related to Russia's
brutal war on Ukraine and its people
these shocks have held back both
productivity and labor Supply
we describe our assessment of these
shocks in the monthly policy report
published today I will just point to one
important part of this story
as this chart shows since the start of
the covert pandemic we've seen a large
increase in the number of people who do
not take part an active part in the
labor market
some of this rise in economic inactivity
is caused by the population aging
but as the chart shows those age 65 and
above account for only around a third of
the increase that's shown in the blue
bars
there's also been a marked increase in
inactivity amongst 50 to 65 year olds
that's the orange bars
many say they've retired early making a
choice about the life they would like to
live
at the same time however many people
report that they are affected by
long-term illness
a number of these people say they are
unlikely to come back into the labor
markets
this significance and lingering fall in
the labor Supply weighs on the UK
economy's potential
and you can see this directly in this
chart
the white solid line is the
participation rates the share of people
over 16 who take part in the labor
market
it fell sharply with the onset of covid
which is not unusual by International
standards
but it is not reversed which is unusual
we think there's four will take some
time to unwind so we've revised down our
estimates of the trend and participation
with persistent effects from covert
adding to population aging
as this next chart shows as a result of
the rise in inactivity combined with the
effects of the other shocks I briefly
mentioned the level of potential supply
has not yet regained its pre-pandemic
level
Supply growth is weak by historical
standards hence we assume that the level
only recovers gradually
this is the first key judgment
underlying our February forecast
the second key judgment is that the
squeeze on real incomes from high energy
prices and the path of Market interest
rates continue to weigh on demand
economic output is therefore expected to
fall slightly throughout 2023 and into
2024.
this is nevertheless a much shallower
decline than expected in the November
monthly policy reports
this chart which we've used at recent
conferences at press for conferences
shows that the projected downturn in the
economy while still technically a
recession by a common definition is now
significantly milder than past
recessions
that's the purple solid line by the way
let's draw a fall of Grace domestic
output and the purple line is less than
one percent which compared with three
percent or more in the 1980-1990 and
2008 recessions
that's the blue red and yellow lines
respectively
in part the smaller decline in output
reflects the fall in Energy prices as
well as the fall in the market implied
path for bank rate since the November
Monastery policy report
and related to that the moderation of
rates on new mortgages from the elevated
levels we saw in the autumn
the part however the shallower downturn
in the forecast reflects a reassessment
of the outlook for consumption
in light of the strength of the labor
market an upside surprise to earnings
the committee now expects a weakening
and labor of demand to be met to a
larger extent by a reduction in
vacancies and in our works but to a
lesser extent by an increase in
redundancies in unemployment
in turn as firms hold on to work as
households May worry less about the risk
of job losses which is likely to result
in lower precautionary saving and higher
consumption than previously assumed
this takes me to the third key judgment
that over the forecast period what
starts as excess demand becomes excess
Supply
you can see that in this chart where
we've added the projected level of
output to the estimated path for
potential Supply
notwithstanding the NPC's reassessment
of the outlook for demand continued
headwinds lead to an increasing degree
of economic slack emerging from the
second quarter of this year despite the
weak outlook for supply
finally our fourth key judgment is on
inflation
in the central projection as I've
described the increasing degree of
economic slack alongside reduced
external pressures leads Consumer Price
inflation to fall below the two percent
Target in the second half of the
forecast
now the committee has retained a
judgment from previous forecasts that
given the pressure from wage growth
inflation will be somewhat more
persistent than the balance of supply
and demand alone would suggest
and so this pushes up inflation a little
in the central projection
while there's still leaves inflation
while below Target in the second half of
the forecast
there continue to be significant upside
risks around this Central projection
if wholesale Energy prices remain at
their current levels for example
Consumer Price inflation would be nearly
one percentage Point higher towards the
end of the forecast
and domestic wage and price Dynamics
could prove more persistent than the
central projection implies
so the course of the economy over the
coming quarters will be a key
determinant of whether these risks
crystallize
so to finish this takes me back to the
monetary policy decision today
headline Consumer Price inflation has
begun to Edge back and is likely to fall
sharply over the rest of the year
now this is of course very welcome
however the labor market remains tight
and domestic price wage pressures have
been stronger than expected suggesting
risks of Greater persistence and
underlying inflation
the extent to which inflationary
pressures ease will depend on the
evolution of the economy including the
impact of the significant increases in
Bank rates so far
there are considerable out uncertainties
around the Outlook
the MPC will continue to monitor closely
indications of persistent inflationary
pressures including the tightness of
labor market conditions and the behavior
of wage growth and services inflation
if they were to be evidence of more
persistent pressures
then further tightening and monthly
policy would be required
looking further ahead the committee will
adjust bank rate as necessary to return
inflation to the two percent Target
sustainably
with that Ben and Dave and I will be
happy to take your questions thanks
Katie
missions please microphone wait till it
comes around you put your name Andrew
media Outlet and we'll kick things off
with Faisal and then Ashley please
thanks Governor fiesel Islam BBC News
just on that language you just mentioned
um if persistent pressures were to
materialize can we conclude from this
that the Assumption or the presumption
could be that rates might have peaked
unless you get worse than expected news
well I think the way I would put that is
you'll see from the statement that we've
issued that we have changed the language
we've used and we've changed it in two
respects
um
in the previous language we had we had a
presumption that if the economy evolved
as the forecast suggested that's in
November then we expected there to be
further rate increase
we also had that word forceful in there
now we have changed both of those points
and I think that reflects the fact that
we've now got a combination of what I
would call you know we have we have seen
a turning of the corner but it's very
early days and the risks are very large
uh and it's really that that I think
shapes where we you know where we go
from here
so if those risks uh you know emerging
if we continue to get overshoots as
we've seen in particularly uh the wage
data and particularly wait the wage
settlement data and services inflation
then we will have to respond to that
because that will be evidence that the
risk these risks are are crystallizing
if of course the forecast were to or of
course the economy were to evolve very
much as the central case of the forecast
yes and of course we would have to you
know we would have to reevaluate as we
would always do Ben did you want to
no I don't think so I mean you'll have
seen that we've you know stressed that
more persistent case and as the governor
said the risks are still to the upside
so I don't think it's clear that it's
not obvious to me looking at this or
looking at what we've written that
somehow we know we've got to a point
where
there's a peak or even that you know
the next move is
equally likely in One Direction or the
other I think the committee is still
very watchful
for signs of persistent we've got a
forecast relative to which the risks are
very clearly and very significantly
skewed to the upside
um
so you know I would put it with that
sort of
Edge to it but you're right that
increasingly over time given the
degree to which we've already raised
interest rates
these data become more more prominent
and future decisions will become more
sensitive to them I don't know you want
to
actually Armstrong from the Sun
um you mentioned about inflation easing
off and obviously we've seen that on um
kind of commodity prices and obviously
shipping but food inflation which is
obviously an essential for all the
households is actually at record high so
wondering how that feeds into your kind
of estimation of the pain for households
and also
um do your does your models also take
into account the reduction in government
support for businesses coming from April
on the energy support because what we're
hearing from a lot of businesses is that
they're very nervous about that and
while redundancies have been very low so
far once that help is removed or
certainly lessened they might have to
take action
yes we do
um and you're right I mean it is it is
quite a sort of complicated picture when
you look at the combination of the
effects of the quite sharp Fallen Energy
prices the government's uh support
package that is in place uh up until
April I think I think I'm right in
saying and how those things interact
month by month
um
and so I think I'm right and saying that
of course at the moment the the level of
household Energy prices is is really
sort of been fixed by that sort of
ceiling that that's put on that when
that ceiling comes off under the current
prices I think the yeah there might be a
sort of one month what I might call Gap
where prices are just and then we would
expect prices to to come down much more
according to the off Jam cap which will
reflect the market curve uh and I would
just take go back to something I said
quite early on in my remarks that that
is also you know important part of the
of the story that inflation Falls more
rapidly in the second half of this year
than it does in the first half of this
yeah the slope and of course by the way
a big part of that is that inflation is
an annual calculation so you've got to
relate all of this back to what happened
last year
just very quickly on on food there's a
there's a graph in the report 2.4
which has some of the underlying
wholesale commodity prices
um we don't forecast the components of
inflation beyond the very near term so I
can't tell you what the forecast
embodies overall in terms of food
process but you can see that
you saw very steep Rises and wholesale
these are in dollar terms but same was
true in Sterling very steep Rises
in agricultural commodity prices you
know 30 sort of thing
um during
2021 and they've sort of come back down
and leveled out since so in time I think
one would expect these very high rates
of food inflation
to stop dissipating and process to level
off
um but you're right you know it's
a big part of the inflation currently as
are more generally these prices of
global traded Goods I mean I think just
to finish I mean if we look at the big
what I call the big three external
shocks that we've seen I mean on first
of all the supply chain shop post covert
then the the energy shock and then the
food shock I would say they're in
different sort of
phases of of their sort of evolution so
I think the supply to Global Supply
Chain shock I think is now sort of
clearly coming off and indeed probably
has been for about the last year
uh energy we've talked about I mean you
know we see it now coming off but it's
at a much earlier stage and food I think
Ben's absolutely right so I mean we've
got this situation where we we see at
the sort of commodity price level things
flattening out but we haven't yet seen
it coming through into the Consumer
Price Index
if I can just supplement that I mean we
as we I mean we have a chart that shows
chart 2.19 shows that food
price inflation is contributing more and
more
to the overall level of inflation and so
I mean as a committee we're acutely
conscious you know particularly
for poorer households you know the share
of their consumption that is food and is
energy these Necessities
um so we're very conscious of of the
challenges that that are being faced and
your point on
redundancies is is exactly right in
terms of where the data has got to so
far we are forecasting a pickup in
unemployment from the current very low
levels one of the drivers for why we
have a more uh it's still a technically
a recession I think we've got a
Peak to trough fall in GDP now of just
under one percent so it might meet the
technical definition of a recession
but it is much milder as Andrew was
saying than we previously had but we a
key driver of why it's milder is that we
have changed our judgment on where
unemployment is how much unemployment is
going to rise so we still have it Rising
through this year but it now Rises by
the end of the forecast period to just
over five percent whereas back in
November we had it rising to some way
over six percent
so things are going to be challenging
and tough
um but the the recession that we we
still have in in the data is is milder
than it was
good as Sue and Ed
hi Sue Chan from the telegraph Governor
you touched in your opening remarks on
reasons behind the rise in inactivity in
the labor market you also say in the MPR
that so far your agents have identified
little sign of people returning to the
labor market due to cost of living
pressures does that does that suggest
that government efforts to get people
back into work may prove futile and what
do you suggest is the best way to
approach this
well I'm not I'm not we do not I'm not
pursuing to be the experts on um what
are Michael's sort of more
microeconomics of of the labor market in
that sense
um
I would also say I I think you know for
the point of view of government policy
that of course it's it's early days I
think this you know this issue is really
surfaced in the last sort of last months
uh and so in terms of the policies on
the labor market you know I think
there's you know there's a clear
intention of the government to get to do
some more but it's early days at this
stage I think
what we see and and yeah we get this
from you know talking to a lot of people
is uh as I said first of all I mean
there's two things going on here
obviously there is a Nash I mean the
population is aging
um and so that you know that would have
happened irrespective of covid uh for
instance so we have to take obviously
that that into account and part of that
and say that would have happened anyway
as it were
the second thing we observe is is that I
said is that in the UK and this is not
the case in the in other countries
what was a fall in participation in the
early part of Kobe does not revert has
not reverse course and that's what makes
the UK stand out really
now what I would say is that I think the
evidence certainly suggests that while
there is an increasing part of the
population that when asked why it is not
returning to the labor market cites uh
long-term health conditions I don't
think that's the proximate reason we're
forgiven for leaving the labor force so
there is this sort of if you like time
Gap in that sense
um
so it's important it seems to me that
you know we know a lot more collectively
from a public policy point of view about
why this is happening and what could be
done to reverse it but that's I say
that's getting beyond our area of
expertise after that I would say
from Sky News earlier on this week no
doubt you'll have seen there was an IMF
forecast for for the global economy
um there was lots of focus on what
happened to the UK
um the UK seemed in their forecast to be
quite an outlier I just wanted to know
you know do you or the bank agree with
that assessment clearly this forecast is
about the UK but I just wonder does it
feel like we're an outlier does it feel
like we're doing so much worse than
everyone else and also you know what are
the reasons if so
um I'll commented um I mean we are our
forecast for UK growth are weaker this
calendar year
um than the Euro area or the US
um but I think one needs to be quite
careful about just taking a snippet of
time and we'll be look to grow more
strongly than your area in 2022 and in
and over those three years as well 21 22
and 23 together
in our forecast and the IMs forecast
so
you know there's a reasonable amount of
volatility over short periods of time
and you need to be careful in general
about those comparisons
having said that I think there are a
couple of things
that could have contributed to the
relative weakness of the UK that are not
just Pure Noise one the governor was
talking about a moment ago
which is the fact that participation
hasn't come back here in the same way it
has elsewhere we don't as Andrew said we
don't fully understand why but it's a
fact
another is that the UK is probably more
dependent on getting fat is more
dependent on gas
and there's a huge difference as you
know between the behavior of gas prices
in Europe and the United States so that
explains a big
part of the gap between growth here and
in your area compared with the US
but we're even more dependent than
Continental Europe
we think of France with all its nuclear
power stations for example
so I think that's another part of it
it may also be and this is what
[Music]
um
pay all the the IMs Chief Economist said
faster transmission of monetary policy
all those things
the participation
the effect of how gas prices and even
the faster transmission and monetary
policy are not things that will endure
forever
so I don't think this had the you know
one should expect this to tell you about
Trends over the next four or five years
brexit
but brexit is as as Andrew said in his
opening remarks has been something that
has pulled down potential output in our
country in our assessment that's been
our assessment for many years as you
know
and we have brought we've not changed
our estimate of the long run effects
but we
brought some of them forward we think
probably they're coming in faster than
we first expected even if the long run
effect is no different
again I'm not sure that's going to help
you explain why growth is weaker having
than the Eurozone in 2023 haven't been
stronger in 2022
um but it you know over periods of time
yes it's having some effect on growth
although ultimately in cumulatively no
bigger in effect than we we assess some
years ago
um but you're right that you know based
on the numbers for trade and some degree
on the numbers for investment
we think those effects have come through
someone faster than we initially
envisaged it's interesting when you look
at the profile with the IMF because the
now profile was that I would say I think
we're pretty similar this year we've
both got pretty sort of you know small
negative numbers actually the difference
is what happens thereafter I think which
is that they have growth picking up more
rapidly than we do that's the difference
really that stands out
well that what you it's both
um the underlying Supply factors that
Ben was just describing and that Andrew
talked about in his opening remarks
um yeah we've done this Supply stock
take we have got relatively weak Supply
growth
um further out weaker than uh pre you
know the the averages we saw that prior
to the pandemic that's actually largely
driven by The Party The the lower
participation that Andrew was was
talking about
um different forecasters that's on the
supply side different forecasters will
will have different assessments of of
the pace of the recovery as we come out
of the recession so you know that's
that that's that's to be expected given
the different judgments we make
and Arty
yeah Larry Elliott of the Guardian
um Governor you say that it's too early
to claim victory in the war against
inflation I just wondered what things
you would require to happen to declare
that Victory would it be a moderation in
private sector pay claims or a rise in
unemployment and if so wouldn't that be
a curious sort of victory for the people
affected by the current cost of living
crisis
well that's a good question I saw I
would I would sort of put it into two
parts
um the sort of what I call it and if you
put it into our forecast the central
case and the risks
so on Central case uh said I think you
know we do need to see that you know
these very sort of pronounced
yet to use the technical term base
effects that are pushing and
particularly on energy that are pushing
inflation down
now you know they are sort of if you
like sort of you know baked in unless
obviously we get some surprise that I
think none of us know about and I you
know in in the in the World At Large and
unfortunately I say that because we've
obviously had quite a few of them in
recent years but other other things
equal
that yeah that story is important but I
think we put greater confidence on its
evolving so then I think we come to the
risks uh uh as you said Larry now I want
to be quite clear I mean it's it's not
um uh a case of a certainly not a case
of us wanting you know stronger stronger
unemployment for instance we've we've
revised as as we've been saying you know
we've revised the unemployment profile
what I would say is that we have been
surprised
um on the upside by private sector wage
settlements so that they are they are
higher than we thought they would be in
the November uh the November report that
is that is the case
um now if you look however at two other
things you get a slightly different
story so that's looking at year on year
comparisons if you look if you if you
redo those numbers to sort of look at
the more high frequency so if you do
three months on three months or so on
you you get a story that it looks as if
it's flattening
and then you take the survey evidence
um which we obviously look at intently
um you see some clear signs in some
surveys that the position is is is
weakening
um
so we will be watching those things very
carefully because they are going to have
a very important influence I mean what
goes on in the labor market at the
moment uh is going to be a very
important determinant and particularly I
would say in Pay settlements he also by
the way you know care about the pricing
side yes
and Andrew showed you a graph earlier
with Services prices we choose that one
because we care particularly about
services but they tend to be more
persistent it's not simply about
wages and the truth is that when they
bid each other up we don't end up
better off
you know what's happened here is that
face with this massive real income
squeeze which is a result of War
pandemic
even though the pandemic effects are not
fading
the attempt to claw that back
for firms to maintain the real value of
the profits for employers to maintain
the real value of their wages
collectively that's not possible
a real national income is inescapable
lower as a result of these shocks
and what happens instead is you get this
period of inflation so it's not that we
you know intrinsically
want lower rail wage growth I don't
think we can ultimately do much about
the level of real wages is that both
wages and prices are telling us about
the strength of this reaction and
therefore the ultimate Persistence of
overall inflation and I would say I
would just add one certainly when we go
around to the country with the agents
and I certainly go around the country
with the agents I would say the story
has evolved and I think certainly now we
hear more stories from from businesses
that they are finding price more
resistance to price setting so certainly
I would say we were picking up
you know some months ago
um from the times
um you've conditioned your forecasts on
the reduction in energy price support
planned for April that would see prices
go up to 3 000 on average now the chance
was under pressure to either mitigate or
remove that that increase due to the the
lack of the less the Lesser subsidies
they have to pay out because of the fall
and natural gas prices now if there were
to be a maintenance of the support at
its current level or a smaller increase
that's to say below 3 000 how far would
this go to lowering your your forecast
for the recession or what impact would
it have on your forecast for inflation
growth and unemployment
well better what's coming I mean I would
say this that there are very and you saw
it I think in the first chart we showed
there are very big energy effects in
this forecast
so I would you know I would sense say
that the cumulative consequence of any
further change is going to be quite a
lot smaller than the effects we've
already got because the big ones are in
there I don't know where you want to no
yeah it says remember that the wholesale
price has come down so much
that the implied retail price I remember
exactly when this happened but at some
point not in the terribly far distant
future
when it comes down below the level of
the energy price guarantee you assuming
the same off-chem pricing mechanism yeah
so at that point it doesn't really make
any difference it would do in the in the
near term because
currently
you know what would it be in the off gem
prize is a good deal higher than the car
the cap is definitely binding at the
moment but you know if you look further
ahead I can't remember exactly I think
it's going to Spring early summer I
think that that starts the wholesale
price has fallen sufficiently that it
doesn't really make that much difference
and so in terms of the medium term
forecast it would make some but I'm not
sure a huge amount
so
Chris Johnson the financial times
Governor it's pretty unusual for the MPC
to put aside its inflation forecast when
making rates decision even the risk
adjusted inflation forecast
and the minority on the committee said
that they thought enough had been done
and that would require then bringing
forward rate cuts which might be larger
than otherwise accepted are you
comfortable with putting aside the
inflation forecast and is this just one
more heave and you're comfortable with
maybe having to cut rates quite soon
more than you otherwise would have to
can I can I if you don't mind interpret
your phrase put to one side the forecast
I'll give you my I'll be honestly every
member of the committee could obviously
do this differently because the forecast
is an input to our policy decision it's
not uh you know it's it's not an as
night follows day thing
and so my own view on this is follows if
you ask me the question which is like a
relevant question to ask do I think this
forecast is my best Judgment of what is
like to have better than any other
judgment I could make I would say the
answer that is clearly yes yes we spend
a lot of time on this forecast
now the however this is relevant to your
question so it's not I set it to one
side and decided to do something
completely different it really comes
back to what I said in the beginning
which is
I from my part I think there is there is
a such a high level of uncertainty at
the moment around how this is going to
evolve
uh that I need to see more evidence that
we are going down that route and
particularly with the scale of the risks
we have around inflation and as I said
we've got the largest upside risk on
inflation in the history of the NPC
that I need to see more evidence that
that you know that that is going to
evolve as as as the central case of the
forecast would indicate and as I said
earlier
if the central if it if it evolves the
economy evolves as the central case of
the forecast suggests then of course we
will set policy according to that
yeah that situation and we will respond
accordingly
and while you know we've emphasized uh
you know the risks yeah I've just come
back to the point I said you know it is
the case that we have changed the
language in the military policy
statement that we've used and that's
quite deliberate
Chris you know the fact that I mean I
certainly didn't put the forecast to one
side
um
and the SKU is sufficiently Big that the
mean projection for inflation under the
market part of interest rates which by
the way has another for what it's worth
doesn't say anything about what we will
do but that market path has another
you know it's a little bit higher in the
near term even if subsequently it comes
off
based on that market profile the mean
forecast for inflation as opposed to the
mo
is pretty close to Target but two years
and I think it's it's difficult for
people who believe and I'm not saying I
do one without I think they probably are
on the committee that the things we
assume in the forecast
for example the stability of inflation
expectations the rootedness that pulls
us towards the target along themselves
depend
on what we do I'm not sure I would but
there are people who believe that
then it's slightly old thing in order to
secure
uh that medium term
you know you may need to act more
aggressively than the central forecast
tells you
uh
but but I completely agree with Andrew
you know in the even if that medium term
for some is given less weight certainly
the modal forecast is given less weight
in the event will be guided by what
actually
happens
I mean the thrustable question is a
perfectly good one because that the gap
between the mean and the mode that skew
is pretty big at the moment which gives
you some idea of the
it's just about it's pretty close for
two years you're right Beyond two years
it continues to fall very true Dave
wants to go I just want to remind one
thing I said in the introductory remarks
and that is yeah we we switched a few
rounds ago to the uh using the football
actually in November didn't we so using
the full Futures curve for Energy prices
actually that was that's true necessary
because otherwise we would have got a
very strange profile of energy prices
using the Recycled random walk
assumption that we use but I did say
if you plug the random walk assumption
back in to what we used to use you get
about one percent higher inflation
yeah let's give you idea of the risk
gives you a sense yeah well you've said
one more points I was going to make but
it does go to the the more General
framing for the for for
this set of policy decisions which for
me we're not putting the forecast to one
side but the forecast is a very
important input into our decisions but
we've had to deal with these shocks that
we've been talking about and the impacts
that they have I mean if you remember
when we were back here in November we
had to put a lot of four a lot of focus
on the conditioning assumptions for our
forecast because you know what had
happened in September and October last
year uh with you know Financial Market
reactions to the then government's
decisions what was happening with Energy
prices these were challenging things for
us in terms of setting out our view of
the future I mean I'm certainly not
putting the forecast to one side but
given the uncertainties as Andrew says I
think I probably have more confidence uh
with the immediate period ahead than I
do with where things are going to go two
or three years out given the risks and I
mean one specific thing and it goes back
to Ed's point I mean we we haven't got
the detail of the IMF update but we
think that they've assumed more
persistence in inflation which is also
what what gives them more activity if
you like they've got wait you know
they've got you know more more wage and
price pressures that feeds through
actually in the in the way they put
their forecasts together to more demand
what we're trying to do is
um
another area of uncertainty for us is
the supply stop take I mean we Andrew
set out in detail and in even more
detail in the in Focus chapter this
assessment of potential Supply
but you know it is affected by these
shocks and it's it's quite possible the
potential Supply could turn out to be
more positive than we've got it over the
next three years all the shocks could
hit even harder and so we we're you know
we're we're having it's not like it was
say back pre the uh the global financial
crisis where potential Supply was pretty
steady grew it grew and demand moved
around it we've now got more moving
Parts more shocks that we're having to
deal with which which prompts quite
reasonable questions like yours but I
think it's but it I think you need to
bear with us that we're sort of we're
using the forecast but we're having to
use it in a rather more nuanced way than
say we did in the first 10 years of the
NPC
so
hi uh Phil uldrick at Bloomberg News I
just um to your to your earlier point
that inflation pressures need to be need
to prove a little bit more persistent
than you are currently projecting to
require uh further policy reaction
um you also predict through the agent's
report a six percent increase in Pay
settlements the record high this year
does that imply that six percent uh pay
Rises are sustainable
um with the inflation Target over the
long term and just on potential output
we've got 0.7 Trend rate of growth which
when was when was the UK
long-term performance ever as Bleak as
that
well there's something I'm not sure if
anybody wants to come in on on pay
settlements I just want it might be
useful to just give you a flavor of the
wheat as you I think you may know at the
beginning of each calendar year that our
agents do a pay survey and we we draw on
that for the forecast and uh as we have
done this time
and
six percent is is is in a way quite
similar to numbers they were telling us
sort of in the sort of throughout some
parts of last year but what they did
tell us this time is that you know firms
are telling them that they would expect
that number to sort of come off as the
year goes on
um some months I mean firms are not that
I mean it's too early I think for firms
to be very precise about that but that's
that's I think what they think is the
sort of the direction if you like of the
overall movement so I think that's
important to bear in mind in terms of
you know how it might evolve uh Ben yeah
no I mean the simple answer your
question is six percent sustainable the
answer is with all consistent with a two
percent inflation Target and
productivity growth of 101 was on the
answer is obviously no but then we don't
expect the play growth to stay at that
level
I mean that's why you know in the medium
term inflation including underlying call
and stuff like that that also comes down
just to show you something that's
consistent with what the governor said
about the very the higher frequency news
if you look at 2.23
which is a graph of various
indicators of pay growth alongside
the official series which happens to be
in a sort of light blue color in this
thing there are some that are coming off
some that we look at so
you know as I say two-part answer
no six percent is not consistent but
then we don't think it's going to stay
though
I know but then look the forecast has
something close to that for the end of
this year and still it has subsequently
inflation coming back down to Target
okay
if I'm just coming on the potential
Supply Point Phil I mean we set out on
page 75 table 3A
the the forecasts that you're referring
to I think for the three years of the
forecast we have potential Supply
averaging just under one it's 0.7 in the
in the final year as I said earlier and
consistent with at what Andrew is saying
in his opening remarks the driver of
that is actually
um potential labor Supply growth if you
look at the productivity line
it's growth is averaging below one but
then the average 0.5 in the decade from
2010 to 2019.
and if you're looking for I mean we
don't we show in the columns here we
have the pre-global financial crisis
decade 97207 when growth was a lot
stronger then we showed the period since
2010 I'm hazarding a guess here but I
would think potential Supply growth was
pretty weak in the period from 2007 to
2010 given the credit crunch given the
shocks that were hitting the global
economy from the financial crisis you'd
have to kind of go back to look at that
but that would be my whether it would be
as weak as we're forecasting is another
matter but the point is as Andrew was
emphasizing what's driving it potential
Supply to look so unusually weak is
labor Supply growth rather than
productivity which is actually sadly
been weak for for many many years
Bill and Marine
oh yeah Bill Schomberg from Reuters um
just ties right into the question I was
going to ask um the Outlook is weak you
know got the economy barely growing this
year sorry Contracting this year
Contracting next year barely growing in
2020. five uh you've got this very weak
Supply I mean uh potential growth rate
is labor Supply really the the key to
this can you perhaps illustrate what
would happen to the growth to the supply
the growth potential of the economy if
we were to able to get activity back to
the levels before the pandemic and to
the second very um a second question
uh did anybody argue in favor of keeping
the word forcefully in the statement
well I'm I'm not going to answer the
second question I'm afraid directly
because we don't sort of in a sense give
away that level of detail in the
discussion because what emerges is you
know is the view of the committee and
particularly The View
um of a majority of the committee so
it's important I think that we you know
we we sort of preserve that in terms of
the argument because you see that you
see the outcomes that were and the
outcome is the word forceful does not
appear in there and that's that's
important
I think in terms of Labor Supply where
oh sorry in terms of the supply side
where I would start from I think Dave
really is in sense just answered the
question in a way which is the the
position on labor Supply is uh unusually
week now part of that as we've been
saying I think we have to accept or
recognize
is a long-term feature of an aging of an
aging population
so I mean what I was saying earlier I
think yeah it would have happened
whether covet had happened or not
um but that is not the only part of it
there is clearly another substantial
part of it in terms of inactivity and
that's going to be the importance
therefore it seems to me of uh of
tackling that labor Supply issue but as
Dave was also saying I mean you look at
the history of product you know the
productivity it has uh you know it has
varied at the time and it is you know
it's been it's been weak in the last
decade or so uh since the financial
crisis
just to say we put some of this in the
in Focus chapter what's clearer now is
just how weak manufacturing productivity
has been on the latest vintage of of
data and we we posit some some potential
um reasons and hypotheses for why it's
it's been so weak but compared to say
five years ago when people were talking
about the productivity puzzle a lot and
right that they should continue to do so
it does look more focused on
manufacturing now less say on you know
Trends in financial services pre and
post the global financial crisis those
actually haven't changed as much it's
manufacturing which really seems to be
bearing the brunt in terms of the UK
productivity story I didn't even
remember just emphasize Dave's important
distinction between labor productivity
in theory what matters for real wages
is productivity
the aggregate labor Supply matters too
but if you're thinking about sort of per
capita things and
average wages are a per capita concept
it's productivity that matters more and
as Dave pointed out our forecasts are
not much weaker so the important respect
to the question that Phil asked the
answer is that unfortunately there'd be
in that bleep for a while
there's a productivity growth which is
what matters more for as I say for the
growth of rare learnings
where wages good I am Marine Khan from
the times a question about the the
long-term productivity Supply the supply
projections can you explain what you
mean when you say brexit is having a
maybe a faster impact than you would
have suggested but no overall difference
in the overall impact
um and also have you begun to
disentangle the brexit impact on labor
Supply so the bank has consistently said
that you know EU workers are
non-fungible in the sense that the
migrants coming from outside the EU are
not necessarily filling the jobs that we
used to have filled by people who are
taking benefit of of the free movement
of people
um did you underestimate that impact
that non-fundability and these are also
driving parts of the labor Supply and
just a general question about the the
impact of supply and falling Supply
there's an argument that secular
stagnation will become re return as the
norm uh in the next few years
potentially when interest rates are
normalized
um would your projections on the state
of the UK's long-term Trend growth
suggest that cellular stagnation would
also return the UK well I mean like a
couple of points
um
I'm brexit um let me two points
um it is unusual it is very hard at the
moment to separate out I think in any
any sort of precise way the effects of
brexit covid and uh the energy prices
we've got these shots going on together
and we get shops in the sort of
technical sense there
I think our best judgments at the moment
is and I think you you captured it
actually as that
um we haven't necessarily changed our
view of the long run impact from the one
we set out some years ago but the long
run impact seems to come through more
quickly that seems to be the evidence
indeed by the end of the forecast
Horizon uh as things stand that long run
impact would have come through
yeah we had an overall estimate of I
can't remember on productivity three and
a three and a quarter percent yeah we
had it coming through pretty gradually
we just think we're getting to that
number slightly faster
given the evidence we see on trade and
investment and the comparisons of those
with other
countries that's why
and on the point about sort of Labor
Market mismatch which is the word
economists used to represent exactly the
thing you say
it's possible
that you know
um
the effects of you know relative changes
in migration from one part of the world
to another have affected that but I
don't think we can say definitively that
that's been the case
Chuck
I'm sorry
um Jack Bonnet from City am we've
obviously talking quite a lot about the
supply side
um weekly so mainly its impact on on
growth I just wondering whether or not
the committee had a view on the impacts
of inflation in the long run you've
obviously mentioned that quite a lot of
the problem has been we're going into an
Asian Society now and participation is
naturally falling in response to that
does that mean we're also going into a
period of potentially higher inflation
so we I don't think there's any
particular reason to think that I mean
lots of you've seen lots of variations
in the rates at which society's age I I
can't think off the top of my head
there's any particular correlation with
inflation
so I don't think that need be the case
no I mean it's sorry as soon as it
probably has been true in our forecast
and our assessment that this early
retirement
as opposed to the stock that's been very
long just just a result of Aging
may have had an effect on the gap
between demand and Supply because when
people age when people retire forgive me
a saving rates suddenly fall
and so if suddenly someone brings
forward that date it may have
contributed to some degree to the
current rates of of inflation a bit I
mean nothing like the extent to which
energy and food prices have done
and I think you made that point yeah and
I mean you can I don't think we would
make what I mean some people describe
and probably I have in the past you know
potential suppliers being some kind of
speed limit on the economy and we would
recognize that it you know it is the
level of output the economy can sustain
without adding to inflationary pressures
that may have applied recently for the
reasons
um Ben says but I think more generally
when you look at our forecast we're
opening up over the next three years
we're opening up spare capacity as
Andrew was saying I.E demand is weaker
than Supply so as you move further out
in our forecast it's certainly not
acting as a it's not constraining growth
however your more General long-term
point if you can get potential Supply up
that means that the economy can grow at
a faster rate over the long term so it's
definitely worth any policies that will
increase labor apply or will increase
productivity those have been the focus
of successive governments ever since
I've you know been working in public
sector which is over 30 years so
that's not a new idea that you're trying
to increase potential Supply in the
economy it's just it's very weak at the
moment
from The Daily Mail
the NPR talks about the impact of fiscal
tightening and tax Rises and um
specific policies introduced in the
November awesome statement and it
suggests that the impact of these will
by the end of the period reduce the
level of GDP by
0.4 percent
so it seems like you're saying that
fiscal policy tax Rises fiscal
tightening is effectively a handbrake on
on growth and is this a frustration for
you as you formulate monetary policy
particularly with the outlook for GDP
stagnating
um all the way through to 2026 and
supplementary one is just about Market
reaction today on the path of interest
rate of interest rate suggested it's not
going to go up to uh 4.25 later this
year
is there any reaction any comment well
let me say well I'm just about something
I don't even want to get on the market
rates
let me say two things one
um and what you see from I think the
chart you're referring to is that fiscal
policy is and we obviously let me say
condition all our views on announced and
announced government policy we don't do
anything other than that
and what you see of course is the fiscal
policy does move from being somewhat
supportive to then tightening as the
time goes by and that's consistent I
think with the Chancellor's
announcements last late last year
um and that that brings me to the second
point which of course is that it is
important that we have sustainable
fiscal policy I'm gonna you know that's
what that's the furthest point I'll make
as a central bank Governor but it is
important that we have sustainable
fiscal policy
and just on your other point
um we took the very unusual step
extremely unusual step in November of
commenting on Market curbs but I'm
afraid normal from your perspective
normal Services resumed and we're not
going to comment at all on Market
reactions
Francine and then essay
oh well done
Governor that the tight labor market May
mean that inflation doesn't quite fall
to two percent for a long time
well let me I uh let me let me put the
words long time to to one side and come
back to that I I think yeah I think we
laid out pretty clearly that there is a
one of the risks that we've identified
and the profile of inflation comes from
the tightness of the labor market
uh and we see that both in in the
quantities and the prices we see that
both in terms of of the overshoot and
pay settlements of the fact that if you
take you know someone like the vacancy
to unemployment ratio well it has come
off somewhere it remains very high by uh
by historical standards so there is
tightness in the labor market and of
course it also goes back to the supply
side question that we've been talking
about a lot during this uh during this
conference
um so yes that is that is a big risk and
we are you know gonna have to watch it
very carefully I'll come back to what I
said earlier on which is
um in terms of you know watching the
data we watch all the data but if you
ask me which which data are going to be
particularly uh significant in the in
the period to come labor market would
would certainly for me be well up there
now I I I would have I would sort of not
go to the sort of
a very long-term interpretation of your
phrase long term because I think
Ben was saying earlier
there are a lot of other factors coming
to play there
um as Dave was saying I mean it's
important as we're seeing that public
policy and government policy of course
you know is is you know increasingly
focusing on this question of Labor
participation welcome that it's
important so I think that's that's the
caveat I would have to your long-term
point
over the long term we will policy to
ensure inflations at the Target yes
yes I'll send from The New York Times
um yesterday the Federal Reserve said
you know a few more rate increases and
then they're going to reevaluate the ECB
just said one more and then reevaluate
you just said you know we're turning a
corner here do you have any concern that
globally financial markets might decide
to declare victory for you
um earlier than you're ready for and
start loosening conditions in a way that
makes it harder to restrain kind of the
restrictions you need to ensure that
inflation goes down over that kind of
medium term period Well the message I
mean the message you know for everybody
I mean financial markets included I
think is this
um yeah there is a very clear path
downwards and inflation and as I said to
Chris
um if you ask me is you know is is that
your most likely path I would say yes
but there is a lot of uncertainty around
it there's uncertainty both around the
brand actually the the degree of risk
and the timing as well and I you know
the message I would give to financial
markets is that you have to watch this
we all have to watch this very carefully
and we will set policy to reflect
you know how the economy evolves and how
those risks evolve just one point of
clarification
you said I'm not going to comment on
whether what they actually said but you
made some comments about what the other
central banks have said about their own
policy rate and then you said that we've
said we've turned a corner the turn to
Corner was with respect to headline
inflation it wasn't a remark about bank
rate just to be clear so they're not
quite like for like those comparisons
the only other thing I'd say is
probably we think the role of
Equity prices in particular
and therefore these overall Financial
conditions indices
the effects of those on growth are
probably bigger in the United States
than they are here so there's a lot of
emphasis on the FCI stuff
we look at them certainly
um but I don't think they necessarily
capture what we believe the whole stance
of policy
on the economy and ultimately on
inflation
thanks very much everyone
thank you very much thanks